but speaking of hot topics there is one
that came up recently that i thought
were just so
incredibly [ __ ] stupid that i do want
to talk about it
i tweeted about it yesterday as well oh
i was the crypto the crypto scam by
the phase clan i tweeted about that
yesterday i'm not being funny
if you believe in any financial advice
from someone from the face
you have to start questioning what's
going on but i know most of these kids
are not
i don't think most of them are young
because how the [ __ ] do they have crypto
wallets
um very very very very naive parents
i am r out the loop can you explain to
me what is right
of course so um faze clan which if you
don't know are an absolutely massive
organization on youtube yes um
they have members that um i cannot
distinguish to save my life they all
sound
and feel very familiar and there's also
like 70 of them
yeah there's like i don't know how many
there is there's about like i think
there's less than 10 of them they
they're all massive no
there's more than 10 is there there has
to be i just know that they are gamers
they're gamers so yeah they're mainly
gamers they mainly do you know
uh very clickbait videos a lot of them
cover very
hot games so like when it's fortnite
they're fortnight you know and then they
kind of pick up the biggest creators
most of them have over like five million
subs most of them have over 10 million
subs
yeah and uh a few of them have recently
started
uh you know uh advertising
cryptocurrencies
oh i like where this is going yeah this
seems to have been uh a concerning topic
with influencers in general recently
where
they've been you know i don't mind you
talking about your crypto investments
and whatnot but there's a difference
between that and being like
hey invest in uh whatever so there was
the big scandal this time was that
uh there was a coin called like save the
kids yeah
it's literally called like this is like
a parody like this is what like a parody
movie would call this scam
you save the kids you know what i mean
yeah yeah and they had like all of they
had this like flashy promotional video
where all of them were like
i'm here to save the kids like all the
face club members like i'm holding to
save the kids
and so they they they advertise this
coin that
they also like had someone who helped
them develop it so they were they were
in from the start developing this coin
making it so they had all the coin
before even went live
and if you don't know how cryptocurrency
works i'm not going to explain it
because i don't think there's videos
on youtube frankly i don't know all i
know is that they had the money
before they had access to this this
marketplace before anyone did they
already had all the money
they promoted the [ __ ] out of it i mean
it's typically called a pump and dump
right so you promote the [ __ ] out of it
the value goes up
and then you sold they sold all of their
coin
immediately so when this coin went up in
value and it went immediately to [ __ ]
yeah
like there's actually graphs of it that
you can see where it's like day one it's
like up here and then it just goes
yeah so i think it started off like one
one one penny it was worth yeah
these coins and then it was well i think
now it's worth less than a hundredth of
a penny
i think it's like a thousandth of a
penny it's even less it's ridiculous it
sounds like that should be illegal
i think well it might be stuff like this
in the stock market it would be very
illegal
for wall street because
i feel like i'm just the guy watching
the [ __ ] show that is crypto i don't
really give a [ __ ] about getting into
crypto but i love keeping up with it and
love seeing the drama
and they're always just at each other's
throat on whether they want regulation
or not
yeah um and so that's the debate of do
should it be regulated to stop [ __ ] like
this from happening
um but even then i think the if the fec
uh
or i think that's what it is wanted to
investigate i think they could arrest
them
and yeah someone actually found their
wallets their crypto wallets which is
unique to the person who
buys or sells a crypto you can only have
one or you can get one
but it's a unique thing that everyone
can see because crypto is public
and so people managed to find uh the
face clan's wallets
right and saw that at least one of them
a bunch of them
a bunch of them all sold immediately
which shows that they kind of had some
malicious intent
yeah and one of them had done like four
of these schemes
and sold immediately every single time
and bear in mind
if this was for you know these people
have like 10 million subs so their
income is probably already over
you know seven figures a year yeah right
and so they're doing these
i mean they're just scams that's
blatantly what they are i mean these
guys these are just
call it what it is it's a [ __ ] scam
it is a scam they're running these scams
that could easily
put them in jail and some of them only
made like 50 grand
and don't give a role 50 grand is a lot
of money it's a lot of money but in
retrospect of how much they're already
probably making or if they did a raid
[ __ ] shadow legends they'd get 100k
are you kidding me like
like why why are they risking their life
for 50k
that's not a lot in in like in the grand
scheme of things for the amount that
they're making for what they're putting
on the line
as well that's like going into tax
evasion to like save a tenner or
something like that
like what the what the [ __ ] are they
doing at least at least when you rob
people you can wear a ski mask
they're [ __ ] promoting it publicly
and then their [ __ ] wallets are
popular
they were like making millions that's
what it sounds like
it sounded so elaborate and so like
crazy that i was like these guys must be
getting millions from this no they made
like 60k
and it's like you guys are so [ __ ]
dumb this is the dumbest thing i've seen
like at least with the [ __ ] uh the
whole t martin
uh cs go gambling yeah yeah because
that's literally reminds me of yeah at
least
he was probably making millions yeah if
you're gonna
like risk your life at least like that's
what pissed me off the most about this
i'm like
you guys are so [ __ ] dumb i couldn't
believe this like when i saw it
just upload a couple of vlogs just out
of shitload of minerals on you probably
make the same amount yeah yeah
it's just i you know i've watched
channels that like are dedicated to
finding these like crypto scams and
there's so many
youtubers doing this it's so appalling
it's so sad
it's pretty fun like the more the more
like i've seen people reacting to it
i've just never looked into
what was going on myself it just seems
like yeah very much like the cso
um skin gas scam right whatever
i forget what that scam was called kind
of like that but at least
at least gambling you know there's
something there you just lose with it
you're just getting scared at least you
get skins
yeah i don't know man it's like and
there was a bunch of other youtubers
were doing it too right like quite long
i think like i mean ricegum i think was
involved in those
[Music]
sam pepper is a well-known very
well-known prank channel and he was
canceled a while back
of course he is known he's very popular
right now because he's doing crypto
scams
are we just going through like the
[ __ ] top 10 list of youtuber scumbags
that we're looking
that's what it sounds like a youtube
scumbag that they're doing probably
doing for a show
they're literally doing this doing it as
well logan paul yeah look
was pushing this [ __ ] of course he was i
i've never
been one for like you should lose your
platform for stuff but i genuinely think
if you're doing this [ __ ] you shouldn't
be allowed on youtube
yeah of course how youtube lets like
people who do this [ __ ]
like still upload and like because it's
you know we already have a bad enough
rappers youtubers
yeah we already have like one of the
worst reps of any reps
the last thing we need is every single
person over 10 million subs [ __ ]
shilling
garbage crypto that is blatantly a scam
and it's so shitty as well right because
like
internet personalities are like built on
like a trust
right of like i love this content
creator trusting you know i love these
people
what i want to know is how they're
getting away with this [ __ ] how
there's no regulation you know as much
as
you know we a lot of people don't want
websites to get involved rightfully so
because youtube and twitter where they
normally try and enforce [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] mess yeah
it's kind of this thing of like well
maybe there should be exceptions
when they're notably being scammed yeah
yeah i mean i mean i mean
i don't even know is if what they're
doing is illegal but i assume if it is
illegal then that is like a genuine
reason to deeply
it definitely feels illegal it
definitely feels illegal this definitely
shouldn't feel illegal whatever they're
doing
like that's literally like being like
i'll give you ten dollars
jk it's ten cents you know it's like
it's literally that
i just don't understand what sick [ __ ]
like builds up this this
audience right and then just is like all
right i'm just gonna take that money
like well that's again that's what's the
shitty thing right it's like it's built
on a trust system your viewers trust you
as a personality
they'll listen to anything you say right
being like oh well if my favorite
content creator says i should do this
i should probably do this and so i feel
like it works both ways right it's like
obviously
influencers are kind of [ __ ] in a
sense because they're
literally taking advantage of a fan base
they trust them
but at the same time the viewers aren't
really thinking for themselves right
they're not thinking like hmm this might
be a scam it's hard right because
you do like it's unfortunately people do
build up trust yeah for some reason
they trust this someone with the name
phase in front of their name yeah
you know it's just it's sad man i just
the idea of someone
like looking up to this this person who
plays fortnight or whatever
yeah clearly i'm very knowledgeable
about what face clan
does you know this is the most gamer one
out of three and even he's having
trouble describing them
it's that side of gaming that is
blatantly marketed towards you know
under 16 year olds yeah yeah
you know i'm not really into that yeah
you know and it's uh it's sad it's just
really sad i just don't
understand how you could go to a meet
and greet ever and look your fans in the
eye and be like i'm so glad to meet you
it's like
a [ __ ] thank you for changing my
[ __ ] wallet when you meet them you
know what i mean like it's
it's one thing to like e-bag in various
ways but
like i think this is just like steel
isn't it you're just stupid
because like what blows my mind hearing
the story is that there are so many
legitimate ways to make money that is
not this shady i mean [ __ ] you know like
how much did
logan paul and jake paul make from like
a [ __ ] boxing match right
that's what blows my mind is that logan
paul must have made what 20 30 million
dollars from that fight and then he's
here promoting
dink donk coin ding whatever it is
dumbass
what are you doing man you're already
[ __ ] rich as [ __ ] do you really need
to do this yeah
this is what blows
i've thought that you know as much as
they are scumbags and everything they're
also like [ __ ] geniuses for being
being able to monetize how [ __ ] hated
they are yeah because they've made
millions
from doing boxing matches so i'm just
like well okay that was that was pretty
clever i'll
i'll give you i'll give you the rep for
you know monetizing you
at least you're putting your body on
yeah monetizing you being a scumbag but
then there's just this
which is you know it's not nowhere near
as profitable
as getting punched in the face and i'd
much rather get punched in the face
thank you very much
honestly honestly yeah honestly geez
if i had the options to get punched in
the face or do the sponsorship i'd be
like just punch me in the face
yeah every time do i get paid the same
amount yeah
[Music]
would you rather right would you rather
get punched in the face for 20 million
dollars
or scan people out of crypto for fifty
thousand dollars or do an illegal act
which was your armada it's
sad the whole thing is so sad every time
i think oh yeah youtube is a
lot of them are pretty bad huh and
guaranteed as well like when this does
break out into like the mainstream if it
hasn't [ __ ] already like news outlets
gonna pick it up they're gonna be like
these youtubers are doing blah blah blah
and you know what sucks is that yeah
there might be douchebags but at the end
of the day a lot of these guys are like
the faces of youtube yeah so seeing them
you know
being like represented of youtubers
as a whole and doing these like shitty
things it's gonna make out us look like
[ __ ]
even though we're sitting here literally
laughing at them for being how
[ __ ] dumb they want yeah it sucks i
mean
i always look at that side of youtube
and it's just so alien to me because i
don't normally keep up with like
how can i say like the kind of the kind
of like
side of youtube which is mostly like i
guess based in la and
mostly like aimed towards yeah like the
la youtube scene right yeah the la
youtube scene
being is it's like a different world to
me i don't get it sometimes
um yeah and i i i would like to say that
they don't obviously represent all of
youtube but i think
that's obvious to like most of our
audience because i feel like there's
very little audience
um yeah like crossover between our stuff
and then oh yeah
to begin with but that's why i'm holding
trash taste coin guys make sure they
have those tt
coins hold your diamond hands
monkey
my god